Hello and welcome. It's September 15,
2023 and we're at the Active Inference
Institute in active guest stream number
56.1. Today we have Gregory Sargent
Petri and we'll be hearing a talk
followed by a discussion on geometry of
world model influences behaviors. First
there'll be a presentation and then any
comments that people have in the live
chat or any other questions. It will be
great to talk. So thank you a lot for
coming, really looking forward to this.
So please to you. Thank you
very much, Daniel, for the invitation
first, it's really very happy to be able
to present this work here. So it's a
work around some models of
consciousness, at least some
computational models of consciousness,
some part of consciousness, and how it
can help to generate different kind of
behaviors, especially when we think
about, let's say,
artificial agents. So I'm Gregor
Santui. It's a work in collaboration
with david Rodrof, kenneth willie
Ford, Daniel Benka. In fact, it's not
just one work. It'S a collection of
works that have been on for already
around ten years. So if you want to know
more. About this group and the work that
we're doing, you can go on the page, on
my personal Web page, and there's a link
to PCM HTML, and. There'S a summary
of all the work. We'Ve been doing and
some summary of. The work we've been
doing and also of some articles that can
be relevant on this subject. So today
we'll focus more particularly on two
articles. So one that is accepted and
will appear very soon, the other one
need to resubmit, which give formulation
of, let's say,
autonomous agents or let's say
mathematical formulation of agents that
have a world model that is structured
geometrically in such a way that this
world model captures some features of
consciousness. So the first article is,
let's say. The review of the
experimental results that. We have and
the most recent formalism. That we have
on our work, which is the
literature on POMD partial cerebral
stream process, which is optimal
control, stochastic optimal control.
And we just try to tweak a. Bit this
formalism to introduce the ideas. With
how you can include inside of the world
model of the agent some. Ideas on
consciousness and still continue to.
Have algorithms to do inference to find
optimal policies and everything. The
Zecholia article focuses more
particularly on how changing the world
model of the agent can change its
behavior, in particular the
relationship, the geometry of the world
model, the way that it perceives its
environment and the way it acts with
respect to for agent strategy. So the
way that it looks for something, so it
will change its behavior in looking for
something. So I will start by presenting
a. Bit what are all these terms? So,
world model, why you need it. What is a
foraging strategy? How can you define an
agent that is looking for a certain
object? In particular, what is an
exploration based on Curiosity or let's
say more technically epistemic value.
So let's consider the setting where you
have, let's say, a real world, so that's
the space that surround us, 3d space.
You do a setup where you have an agent
which is, let's say, a solid it has a
solid frame, so it has a center three
axis. What is in front, what is on its
side, what is above? Above it. And it's
looking for an object O, which is itself
a solid inside of R three. And all the
configuration of the agents and the
objects they are defined by, let's say,
a reference frame that is external and
that characterizes completely their
configuration inside of this world.
Now, the agent A, what it wants to do is
to find for the object O. But it can
only have some noisy observation of
where the object O is. So to be able to
find O, it needs to have some atriorian
where O should be to be able to plan
the consequences of its actions with
respect to where O will be once it has
moved and to update,
to be able to plan how the observation
can act with respect to updating its
prior. So, in another words, so you have
an agent and the agent is looking for O.
It thinks that O is, for example. In
this direction, on the right. So it's
going to move towards the right and
makes an observation. If it doesn't see
O, it's going to change its belief on
where O is. So this is a very standard
formalism that you can find like in
POMDP stochastic optimal control. But
the one other point we want to really
emphasize is the fact that the agent A
has its own frame of reference and the
way that it's going to give the
coordinates of the object, the way that
it will trace where the object is, is
using its own way of computing the
coordinates of O. So it has its own way
to measure where O is. So it doesn't
have to refer to a global frame, a
global coordinate system, to be able to
know where O is. So for example, I am
always centered on myself. When I move,
I see the object. I don't think about
me moving, but I think about the object
moving. And this is because when I move,
I change my frame. So the way I'm going
to reference the object is going to
change accordingly. And the point we
want to introduce is the fact that you
can have several ways for the agent to
define its own coordinate system with
respect to its environment. And this is
a key feature that we want to capture
in terms of modeling. But also we think
that it is something that is very
structuring with respect to models of
consciousness. Because when you consider
more generally an agent.
Let'S say, that has a world. Model in
which it has its own point of
view perspective on this world model.
You kind of start tackling
the problem of how to introduce a point
of view on the environment of the agent.
How can you introduce, in the way that
it is going to encode its environment,
a certain point of view? And in
particular, if you think about. It in
terms of the role of. Space to be able
to take into account your own
perspective on the environment. You can
see that if you take away everything
that fills up the space, you keep just
the space itself.
The space allows you to, let's say, to
structure the way that you are going to
fill in some information about the
environment. And it's centered on your
own point of view in a way that when
you're going to act, you're still going
to keep the
unfilled space, you're still going to
keep the same way of modeling this
space. The space will stay the same when
you move. When I move, the space is the
same. But I took into account the fact
that I can move from one point to
another in this space without changing
the space. And something that is also
very important is that with respect to
any movement that I can do, the space
doesn't change. So there's no particular
point in space. With respect to the
movements that I do.
Another property that is very similar is
that instead of considering just my
actions and the way that I can change my
frame while I'm doing an action, you can
also imagine taking the frame of
somebody else. So it means that you see
that the space that you use to be able
to structure your environment doesn't
change when you take the perspective of
somebody else. For example, if you
imagine yourself as a solid agent
changing by a rotation your own
solid frame and translating, okay,
so this is something that we will use in
fact as a definition for the state
space, the way that the agent encodes
its environment. And you will see that
there's a natural notion that encodes
this idea that you can change
perspective on your environment, on the
world model that you have of your
environment, simply by introducing
something that's very well known, which
is the notion of a group acting on a
certain space. So this is just to sum up
a bit what we're trying to do. So we're
just trying to do like exploration
inside of an environment, but we're
adding additional information, which is
that the way the agents is going to
encode its environment takes into
consideration the fact that it can
change its reference frame on this space
without singling out any point.
Okay, so what do we mean by perspective
taking more precisely? So how
do we go from the real world? So let's
say the world described by the external
frame that allows you to say the agent
is here and the object is here from the
internal world of the agent. So you just
define a map that will take into
consideration that the agent can have a
first perspective on its environment.
The simplest case in the Euclidean case
is just rewriting the coordinates of O
inside of the frame of the agent,
reference frame of the agent. And then
once the agent moves, its frame solid
frame in the real world changes. And
this induces indeed a transformation
inside of its internal world, which will
lead in a fine transformation.
Okay, but you could imagine also having
other transformations. I don't know if
you can see my mouse probably.
Can you see my mouse or not? No. Okay,
so the map CSI can also be
something else than an affined
transformation. It could be like any
kind of transformation. For example, in
an affined case, the apparent volume of
the object doesn't change. But if you
change this map and consider, for
example, a projective transformation,
as we will describe later, you can have
that the size, apparent size of the
object changes. So we went from
something that is. A bit already very
well known and not very innovative,
which is that you. Can rewrite.
The motions, depends on the. Frame that
you choose to describe them. Into,
saying that you can in fact change some
frames to be able to account for some
perceptive property.
And what we ask also for the agents that
we consider is that they can imagine the
consequences of their moves, which on
their future observations. So this is
something just to say that the agents
that we consider have a notion of
agency, which is that they can plan the
consequences of their actions so that
they can choose the best action with
respect to a certain reward. In
particular, the reward that we consider.
Is trying to maximize a certain
surprise.
So to sum it up, we have an agent that
is looking for certain objects. So it
has beliefs of where this object is.
And the beliefs lives on an
internal state space. So on a world
model of the environment, it can make
observation, which allows it to update
its beliefs and then it can predict the
consequences of its actions so that it
can plan the way that it should act with
respect to a certain objective. So
formally, this is simply the notion of
Markov decision process, or more
generally, like the notion of partially
observable Markov. Decision process
because we do not have. A complete
information of the environment, but only
some observations that are limited.
And it's very related. And let's say.
There'S a strong duality between POMDP
and active inference. So there is really
a strong link between both.
So now what I did in the
way that I presented it so I presented
it the idea I tried to present the idea
of what we're doing. So the general
context POMDPs agents that. Are planning
their action with respect to a certain
objective. Here the objective is to find
a. Certain object and I
give the formal setting for defining it
which are NDP PMDP. And now I will go
one step further and define it
explicitly and I will continue like this
approach for the second part where I
will also present our results and our
specificity, where I'll dealt with a
general statement, then a bit more
precise and then really digging into the
result. So here the classical way to
define a Markup decision process is to
consider that you have a set of
configurations of the environment,
which is the state space or of the world
model in. The way, or at least the way.
That you encode your environment. So
this is something on which you can act,
because the agent, when it makes an
action, it changes the state of the
environment. And the way that the
actions change the environment is with
respect to a. Certain Markov kernel,
probability kernel. So it's stochastic,
which means that each actions changes
the state of the environment. But you
don't know completely. It's not
deterministic. You allow some errors in
the way that it acts on the environment,
and you have a reward for a function
that is associated to the actions that
you can do at time T and also the state
of the agent at time t. A partially
observable Markov decision process is
the same thing than a Markov decision
process. But you authorize to say that
your observation on your environment are
only partial, which means that you do
not have a precise information
on the state of the environment. So the
way that you need to relate observation
and states is through also a probability
kernel, which tells you that if you're
at state, for example S, you would
expect to make a certain observation.
Let's say if you think the object is at
X, you expect to see the object at X,
but with a certain error because you
know that your sensors are also random,
they can make some mistakes and you keep
similarly a reward function. So it's the
same thing that an MDP mark audition
process, but you just allow to have some
to get information on your environment
through observations that are not
complete. In fact, there's a formulation
in terms of partially observable Markov
decision processes. Our particular case
of Markov decision processes, which is
called belief MDPs,
belief Markov decision process and the
only difference that you have between
Markov process and belief MDP is the
fact that the state space is necessarily
continuous in the second case. So POMDPs
can be seen as a particular case of
MDPs. So we
said that the actions of a POMDP act on
the state space and you account for the
consequences of the actions only through
observations. So graphically it means
that you have the state space of your so
the world model of your environment X on
which you reference for example, where
the object is. So the position of the
object and then when you act it induces
a consequence on the position of the
object at time t plus one. And then you
can make an observation of where you
think the object will be or you can make
an observation with respect to where the
object is, depending if you're planning
into the future or if you're really
doing the action. You'Re implementing
the consequence of the actions. In the
real world. The thing that we're trying
to do in our setting is to replace
simply the actions by a change of
perspective. Like I told you, when the
agent acts, its coordinate system on the
environment changes. So you can always
see it in a way passively, where you
just see it as a change of coordinates.
So we want to say that instead of
considering actions on the environment,
we have a space on which there's a
natural notion of changing of reference
frame and actions are simply certain
kind of changes of frames. We also allow
to have some actions that do not
correspond to changes of frames. We just
say that we include the possibility that
some actions are changes of frames and
the changes of frames have something
that is related to all the
transformations that are internal for
the agents. So for example, things that
it knows that a priori,
it's encoded in the way the agents will
interact with the environment.
So the way that we do it a bit more
formally is that we say that changing
perspective is simply through the action
of a group. So for example, in the
affine case, when the agent
moves, a change of frame is an affine
transformation and we say that the world
model. So the state space is simply a
space on which the group acts. So
formally, what does it mean that the
group acts on the space? It's just
saying that you have
a space. S group g.
There's an application that goes that
takes an element from g and S and that
sends back S. In other words, for every
g you can associate a function. From s
to s. And you assume also that it has
good properties, which is that it
satisfies equation one and. That if you
don't move, you stay. At the same place.
So this is like just the notion of a g
space, a group acting on space. But now
if we want to include this in MDPs and
POMDPs, we just assume that the state
space is a g space, that some actions
are some elements of the group, and that
when we choose the actions that
corresponds to the element of the group,
it corresponds to the way that the group
acts on the element. So there is nothing
like very convoluted. It's just saying
that you define the. Collection of
functions which you see as. Changes of
frames and the way that they act. So the
probability kernel from the state.
Space to the state space at time. T to
time t plus one after the action, after
the change of perspective is simply
through the way that the function
changes the state space. So it's just
kind of a way of reformulation. But what
is really hidden behind here is that we
have the structure of the group and that
we don't consider any kind of actions.
We assume that there is more structure
in the actions that we can consider.
And that it's defined in
the way that it's encoded inside of the
geometry. Of the space that we have. So
we don't separate any more action and
state space. We say that the state space
in its geometry encodes already certain
kind of actions which are its change of
perspectives. So there are two case that
we consider. The first case is where the
state S is the Occlusion space and g,
the FN transformation. It corresponds to
translations and rotations of the agents
and changing rewriting the coordinates
of the object inside of the solid
reference frame of the agent. And the
second case where the space space is
a projected space and the group is a
projected transformation.
We described what are the generative
models that we consider and how we can
include inside of the classical theory
of POMDPs the fact that you can take a
perspective on your environment.
Now we will introduce like a classical
notion of epistemic value which will
allow us to define what is behavior,
what is an exploratory behavior with
respect to curiosity. So what it is for
an agent to explore its environment
based on curiosity. So curiosity,
or let's say the drive for exploration
is quantity
that will it's, it's a quantity that you
will okay, so it's,
okay it's so how do you define it?
Just with like very generally. So you
start with the agent has a prior on the
state of its environment, then it plans
the consequence of one of its move at
the next time, at the next time step.
So this changes the prior that it has on
the environment because there's an
action on the environment. So we get a
new prior and now it's going to make an
observation. So it imagines that it's
going to make an observation. Once it
makes an observation there's an
apostrophe, the prior is updated. So you
get an apostrophe. The way that you
define curiosity or let's say epistemic
value is how informative is the
observation that you will do, how far is
the apostrophe from the Apuri? But you
cannot do it for one given observation
because the way that you compute it is
by planning what will happen at the next
step. So you need to consider all the
possible observation that you will make.
So the observations are themselves
stochastic with respect to the way that
you consider with respect to a priori on
the state space of a time t.
As we said, forest actions are
changes of frame. So we can also define
epistemic value for frames for changes
of frames and in particular something
that we gain, that is I think
interesting is that now we have a
function that is defined. On a group
that can be a continuous group. So you
can allow to have for example, if you
want to maximize it, you can or minimize
it, I mean. It depends how you see it.
You could do gradient descent for
example, so you can have more analytical
tools because you're on a space that is
continuous and has some structure. So
now to give the formal definition of
epistemic value, so as I said,
it's based on the quantity C that I will
define now. So if you give yourself a
prior on a space x and you give yourself
a probability kernel. So a stochastic
map from X to Y, stochastic map is
simply saying that for any x you will
associate a measure on Y.
Then you can get a joint distribution on
x and Y, which is simply given by the
product p y knowing x times the prior.
And in fact the quantity C is simply the
mutual information between x and Y,
which is saying how far is the joint
distribution with respect to the
independent distribution, the product of
the marginal distribution on X and on Y.
But this is like you see it appears
everywhere the mutual information. So
this formulation is based on the paper
that is from fiston and all active
inference and the Pacific value. Mutual
information is something that appears
everywhere. But I think that there's a
very. Nice re expression of the mutual
information which allows to give a
better interpretation of this quantity,
which is the interpretation. That I was
discussing in the previous slide. So if
you rewrite mutual information, you can
always see it as the coolBACK lyler
distance between the Aposterior for a
given observation and the prior coolBACK
distance being a way of computing how
far you are, how far the two
distribution are. But you need to look
at the expectation with respect to the
observation that you make. So it's
exactly what I was discussing before.
So then this is like for any
kernel, any kernel from x to Y with
a prior on x. But as we were discussing
here, you have to take into so this
would be the kernel, but you have to
take into consideration that you can do
actions and that your prior R on X. So
the way to compute epistemic value for
this kernel here when having only
the prior on x is that you propagate the
prior by the action on x one. Then you
get a prior on x one and you can define
the epistemic value for this prior and
Markov kernel which corresponds to the
randomness of your sensors which is
always fixed. And this is very
important, this one doesn't change even
if you change frames, the kernel that
you have relating your prior, what you
think about the state space relating the
state space and the observation never
changes. And so explicitly
this means that after a certain action
or after a certain change of frame,
you get a joint distribution on x and y,
which is the following one here. So this
corresponds to the prior propagated on x
one and then the epistemic value is
simply the mutual information of this
joint distribution. So now how does the
algorithm work? The algorithm that
corresponds to defining an exploratory
behavior for an agent that is looking
for so we started with a prior of where
O should be. Then you maximize curiosity
based on some changes of frames
that are around the identity elements
which correspond to not changing frame.
Then you get an action that you can
apply, you propagate the prior to the
next step with this action and then you
just update your Apiori with respect to
a certain observation and then it loops
back. So this is the algorithm that we
consider in the second paper
that was listed in the presentation,
which corresponds to having an agent
that is looking for a certain object.
Its behavior is defined by an
exploratory, is driven by
exploration, driven by curiosity,
taking into account that its state space
is structured by the action of a.
Group, so that its state space is
structured by the fact that it
corresponds. To all the possible ways of
changing frames. So it has inside of the
state space, inside of the geometry of
the state space, all the possible ways
of changing frames.
And this is like explicitly what we do.
So in this context, this is the.
Algorithm that we consider and nothing
else, then we get a very interesting
result. At least I find it's interesting
in. The way that it's presented here. I
find it interesting. And then if you go
more into detail it's because the
Ecclesian case is very particular. But
what you get is that if you look at the
behavior of an agent that is driven by
exploration, by curiosity,
but that has state space structured
by Ecclesial transformation. So the
first case where the agent is simply
encoding its environment in its
reference frame but nothing else, then
it doesn't need to move in the second
case, where the changes of
charts are given by projective
transformations. So the way it's encoded
it's in transformation takes into
account a projective
deformation of its environment, then it
will always try to get closer to the
object. So you have two very separate
behaviors. So this is something that is
I think is very interesting to note.
So before going into the details of how
you can prove this statement, I will say
a bit more about why it's an interesting
perspective point of view on this
subject because and how it goes a bit
further than simply considering this
very simple setting. What you could
imagine is that encoding the fact that
the agent encoding the actions of the
agent directly inside of the state space
of the agent through geometry could be a
way to stabilize the representations of
the agent. And this is something that
we're working on now and there's already
literature in this direction. Okay, so
now let us proof the statement. And to
prove the statement, we need to give a
formal precise statement.
So more particularly what we were able
to show is that if you assume that the
agent has as moves staying still, so
it's allowed to stay still. Then if its
changes of frame are. Given by a fine
transformation, the agent stays still.
Now, in the projected case, if you
assume that the agent is always looking
in the direction of the object, it will
always try to get closer to the object.
Okay? So the idea of the proof is that
what plays the role for drive of
the agent is how big the agent is
appearing to is
the size of the object in the reference
frame of the agent and it's how big it
appears to be to the agent. So in the
first case, the volume of the object in
the internal space of the agent doesn't
change. So it doesn't need to move. In
the second case, if it makes a move,
what is informative is to try to make
the object bigger because once it's
bigger, the apostrophe will be further
from the prior with respect to a certain
observation. So it will always privilege
moves that allow to make the object look
bigger. And in this case, what you can
do is you
can show that this corresponds in fact
to actions or change of frames that gets
you closer to the object. So how do we
prove the results? So, as we said, we
consider a change of frame from the real
world to the internal world. Here, I
didn't consider changes of perspectives
with respect to moves. Here is simply
how you relate the real world to the
internal world. In the Euclidean case
it's clear, it's just that the way that
you write the coordinates of the object
in the solid frame in the projective
case it's not obvious because
there are several ways that you can
relate the solid frame of the agent to
the projective frame. So one way that we
decided to do it is we give some set of
axioms that we consider to be, let's
say, coherent with our own experience of
space. Which is that we feel that we're
always centered on ourself. That the
axis of the soil frame. Of the agent
inside of 3D space. So what is in front
of it or what is on the right, what is
top are preserved. That there is no
point in front of the object that
appears to be at infinity and that that
near to the center of the object, the
volumes are preserved. So when you do
this formulation like this result
is in this article here. So the way that
we relate some solid. Frames like some
solid reference of the agent to some
projectors transformations are in this
article, in particular in proposition A,
one where we show that this set of
axioms limits the set of projected
transformation we can consider and we
will only have this projected
transformation. And so the change of
frames from the external world to the
internal world is given by rewriting the
coordinates of the agent of the object
in the solid frame of the agent and then
applying this projective transformation.
So now what we defined here
are the maps that relate the observation
of the agent.
Back.
So we define the maps in the Euclidean
and projective case that relate the
observation of the agent observation of
the object to the way that it represents
this object inside of its internal world
here. So this
is simply like the POMDP that we defined
before. And now once the agent doesn't
move, it changes its ecclesian reference
frame. So there is a solid reference
frame. So from going from one side
reference frame to another solid
reference frame, you can, by applying
the projective transformation we had
before, define another one that we call
PSI that goes from the state space at
time zero to the state space after
action, after moving. What is very
important is that we. Consider the
Markov kernel associated to a. Noisy
observation to be of this shape here,
which is that if you know that the
object if you think the object is at
point X then you believe that the
observation will be around X in the
ball around X for a ball of a certain
radius, which is a small radius.
Epsilon. Okay? And I need to charge my
computer, so sorry.
So now press epistemic value as defined
curve between the
previous formula.
What in fact that it has a very simple
expression. So the epistemic value of
the prior propagated after the
transformation phi after this changes of
frame phi. So you have a prior here.
You propagate it on x one through. Phi
and you compute the epistemic value.
For this joint for the joint
distribution over x one. And y is given
by this formula here. Well, it's simply
integrating over all the possible places
where the object could be times the
probabilistic volume of the ball
of size epsilon for the propagated
measure and logarithmic of the same
quantity. So this is very direct to
right. You can just compute it and you
find this expression. But what you have
already here is that if you consider an
Euclidean transformation, then the
quantity cubed PSI minus one b epsilon y
doesn't change. So then you have the
epistemic value that is constant. So
basically, if you try to maximize
epistemic value, maximize this quantity,
you can do anything. You have always one
move which is not to move. So you don't
move. It's okay. It's perfectly fine.
Now, in the second case where you. Have
the projective where you consider that.
The way you relate environment and
internal world is through a projective
transformation, then it's more
complicated. And so you need to use
a trick which is that you know that once
an observation has been made the support
of the prior will be smaller. And so
after one step if you suppose that your
epsilon so the size. Of, let's say
noisiness of your sensor. Is small
enough, you have a support that is
of the distribution that's small
enough so that you can do an asymptoteic
development of the quantity in the
interval. So this is an equality, but
this is an approximation here and
now. This is very useful because now
that, you know, doing this in a way
you can say that you just need
to develop this quantity at the point
where the object is really so if you do
it, you get this expression here. And
what appears to play a role is only the
determinant of the Jacobian of a
projective transformation which here in
the accelerated case will be one in
projective case can be many things. So
here also it's not very clear because
how do you define CM? So CM is defined
as a composition of several maps. I
didn't go into the details but it
corresponds to the map that are given by
the changes of frame. So if you have the
occasion space and the internal spaces
after moving you have a change of frame
in the Euclidean space but it
corresponds to also a change of frame in
the internal space. So the way you
define PSI is simply saying that you
inverse the projective transformation
from internal world to external world to
go at time zero. Then you apply the
change of frames and then you apply the
projective transformation to go from
external to internal. And so it is
exactly this formula that you have here
and which is very nice with this. And
then you have the first term that
doesn't depend on the actions that you
do. So you don't need to take it into
account. This one will be one and then
you just need to compute this one. In
fact this one has a very simple
expression so it's expression 2023. And
then here you can directly see which
moves correspond to increasing this
quantity and decreasing this quantity
because we want to increase epistemic
value. And so this is the result this
allows to prove the result that we said
in the first day like in the several
slides before that in the projective
case, if you have enough movements, if
you look at the object then you're
always going to go closer to the object.
A way to interpret it is as if the agent
it was a bit paranoiac or paranoid, a
bit like very uncertain on its own
beliefs. So it knows the object
might be over there but it's always
uncertain. So it needs to go check and
once it's checked it's more certain.
But still as it can always be even more
certain. It will always try to get more
and more certainty.
And so I only presented in this
presentation all the aspects which are
more computational and the algorithm and
some analysis of the algorithm we
considered. But we also have some
experiments on how this setting allowed
to generate different behaviors,
behaviors that we would expect explain.
For example, some illusions like the
Moon illusions. And I invite you, if
you're interested on this, to listen on
to the online talk of
the MOC Four conference that was in
Oxford last week or to check out one
of these three papers. And I would like
to thank you very much for your
attention.
All right, awesome. Wow.
Very interesting and different ways than
how I've seen the POMDP and related
works.
Okay, let's just start off with little
context and then I'll read some
questions and read some questions from
the live chat. So what brought you to
study this question this way?
What question? The question of, okay,
did you come. From a math side and find
consciousness and geometries to be
interesting or vice versa? What kind of
brought you to want to make this
contribution? So at the beginning so
when I did my PhD in maths, I was more
interested, I was interested in, let's
say, all this idea of critical
brain hypothesis. So trying to
understand the way that. The brain
processes information and makes it
something that can be exploited.
So the critical brain hypothesis tells
you that the activity of the neurons is
basically close to a certain criticality
criticality. And the source of
statistical physics because. You can
model the activation of the. Neurons as,
let's say, statistical system like an
Icing model. So I worked a lot on
this. Then there's another hypothesis
that is very. Common, which is the
Bayesian brain hypothesis. And so the
Bayesian brain hypothesis led. Me to
active inference, to learning more about
optimal control, Bayesian perspective on
optimal.
So my advisor was PhD advisor was.
Working with David, and they still work.
Together on trying to implement
some aspects. Of consciousness and how
it can influence influence, especially
with their article on the Moon illusion.
So I was interested in knowing how
this kind of, let's say,
ideas simply. Like in a very naive
way, they interact with the Bayesian
brain hypothesis. And then I continued
in fact, one. Of the lines of my
research is structured like
algebraically structured statistics or
machine learning. And so the way that
they see it very geometrically, in fact,
let's say geometrically or algebraic,
it's not the same. Thing, but it's very
related, is something that I wanted to
understand a bit better, let's say, to
make it in a formal setting so that it's
simply a particular case of what is in
the literature. So it's specifying what
exists in the literature. And this took
some time because I was more on the
active inference, like. The free energy
principle side. So I had to read more
about optimal control Stochastic,
optimal control Pmdps and understand
that in fact, what we're doing is
simply adding more structure on the.
Latent space of the agent, on the.
State space of the agent. And doing
this allows to ask the question like why
is it useful? Why having a state
space that encodes different
perspectives? So the motivation comes
from consciousness study, cognitive
sciences, but why it can be useful for
robotics. And it's always been like my
motivation. Study some statistical
models, more structured models. With
more a priori that can be. Useful for
understanding the behavior of a closed
system like an agent, like a collection
of neurons, like even like molecular
machines. So it's a very long answer,
but it's okay.
Cool. So you focused on the spatial
movement epistemic foraging case.
Is there something special about space
or can we also think about this
perspective taking in terms of, for
example, semantic or a narrative
reference frame?
I think it's a very important question
because up to now all the work reference
will need to space. So the fang is space
in terms of a 3D space and not space in
terms of geometry. And the fact of
writing it as. Geometry allows to get
out from the classical point of view a
space as. A 3D space because you see
that there's more and more like for
example, in geometric deep learning,
there's more and more the use of space
to encode invariance of certain objects.
And these objects are not necessarily
have the three dimensional structure.
You can have objects that have higher
groups of environments. So I think that
it's indeed using. Geometry for other
contexts. And it's really the aim of
trying. To go to this more general
formulation. Is to be able to apply it
to real world models. What I mean by
real world models. It means the ones
that are learned. To be able to have an
agent. In an open environment that will
learn. The way it would learn its
generative model. But they are priori
that it can take a perspective on its
environment and see what it can do. So
we really wanted to get out. From the
least for me, go out. From 3D space and
go to implementing. It completely in
autonomous agents to kind. Of follow
on that. There's a question in the chat,
great talk. I also wonder whether it
applies to any modality, not just visual
spatial, but also text.
Yeah, so for other modalities, like
sound. For example, but I don't know for
applying to text, there's a lot of work
now on large language models and.
All this idea of prompting and having
these models being able to have some
kind of imagination. So you would like
to have these ideas applied in this
context. But for now, it's not the line
that I'm trying to do. So I'm trying to
stay on deep learning. So basically take
standard data set without considering
text and just try to see. How these
ideas, like in geometric deep learning,
can stabilize representations. So it's
not the same that it's clearly other
modalities, especially if we consider
like, multimodal integration. Like, you
try to rebuild the state space and you
don't want to see it only as a vector
space, but. You wanted to see it with
more structure because you want to force
the way. Like you have constraints, you
know, a priority, the constraints that
you're going to have on the way that you
can take a perspective on one moldality
or the other. But it's not for text. At
least not but I think maybe. It could be
used for text, but. It'S not what I'm
doing now. Can I add something about
this question? Sorry,
I just want to rebound on that.
I have the luck of collaborating with
real mathematician. I'm just some guy
with intuition that I've found the right
people to do the work regarding
multimodality. This is important to
understand that this is not about
vision. This is about spatial cognition.
It's supremodal. The claim is that
vision is just one particular way of
integrating information, indeed in an
obviously projective manner, but that's
integrated in a much larger field of
experience than the field of view or the
visual field. And obviously
proprioception touch. When you build a
representation just by touching
something and you get this 3D
representation of that thing
automatically in your mind hearing to
the extent that it's about source
localization and building spatial
representation, all of that stuff that's
the claim of the theory is integrated in
this projective space. There are priors
from memories, there are stuff from
vision, stuff from addition, stuff from
proprioception, interoception, you name
it. All senses contribute to it. So it's
not vision. The claim is that projective
3D projective geometry in that case is
beyond vision. Vision is just actually a
slave to that supremodal representation.
That's the claim. Awesome.
Yeah, please. It's important because I
think we work like a group. There are
several different perspectives. For me,
I'm more on the computational side. So
it's important to have that because
clearly something I won't be able to
answer. Cool. Here's a nice following
question from Vladimir in the chat.
They wrote if the Eg
visual sensors have variable resolution,
for example, higher resolution in the
center, this can naturally lead to
Curiosity based change of orientation
response within your framework. So is it
a question or an affirmation? So it's
for E g, right? If there's variable
sensor precision, for example, higher
precision in the sensor, might you see
any resulting Curiosity associated
change merely based upon the asymmetry
or the structure of the sensor field?
Okay, so I shouldn't say it, but I will
still say it because I don't know if the
paper will go out one day or not. But
this is more attention. This is more
attention than Curiosity. So you can act
on your sensor. So that you can change
the way that you integrate them. And
this really acts as a form of attention.
So I really went into it.
What is the interplay between attention
and curiosity?
I mean,
it's the way you're going to move
basically on the way, the. Way that it
deforms the way that you move. So the
consequences of your actions are not the
same. So basically curiosity is what
drives actions and the way that you.
Choose your. Action with respect to
reward, which is epistemic value and now
attention. Or let's say changing the
sensors is a way to change the
consequences of your action with respect
to, let's say, optimizing this value.
So it's, it's like yeah, I mean.
It'S it's yeah, I don't know if.
I should say it or not, but okay, let's
say it's okay. I think it's a metric.
Basically it acts like a sort of metric
on the space, on the group directly.
So when you have a function, you want to
do gradient descent, you choose a
metric. And the metric is so the
attention will act as a metric and so
the metric will allow you to deform, in
fact, the steps that
you will do. And so I think this is how
it acts. So it's very known that it's
known that the fact that changing the
sensors is related to attention, that's
not something much new, but the fact
that you can directly in our setting
related to groups and you can relate it
to. Changing the metric on the group is.
Something that can be done. And I think
it's interesting.
All right, another question in the chat.
What is a formal framework for learning
geometry from data? How do we move from
empirical data sets, the files on our
computers, and the things that we do
deep learning on take into machine
learning pipelines? And how do we
utilize geometric approaches and
formalize to the kind of analytical
precision that we saw here, some of
these geometric relationships.
So there are several different fields
of how to use geometry on data.
It depends how you see geometry. But one
way is a TDA topological data analysis,
which is basically trying to, let's say
you want to provide learning by
geometric stability property of your
data and try to interpret it as a
certain kind of space. And then you look
at the whole of your space and this is
something that defines your data set.
So this is one approach. Another one is
people doing manifold, so they know that
the data lives in a low dimensional
manifold and they try to learn this
manifold. So that's another way of doing
it. So that's lots of work in this
direction. There are people who are
interested in variance and equivalents,
so more in geometric deep learning.
There are people who are interested in
the same setting on a priorities how to
use geometric aprioris and included in
learning for deep learning,
reinforcement learning. And this is what
we do with this is where many people do
this. It's not just us. For us we try to
focus on this idea of how to exploit it
for reinforcement learning.
So in this setting Epistemic value was
the only driver of action. Is that
so? It's kind of like an expected free
energy except without Pragmatic value.
So we only have the Epistemic term
remaining? Exactly. In fact if you look
at in terms of optimal control and not
by Asian, because you know that there's
this duality that is most of the time
stated in Active Inference where you
have basically a duality between let's
say value
function and a probabilistic version of
value function. So you can encode on
priors, you can encode all your drives
with priors are with the
value function directly. So rewards and
so both are kind of dual and they're
dual in a way you can make this
duality, I don't know if it's explicitly
dual like in some context this sentence
makes sense for Active Inference for me
I'm not completely aware if the duality
is exactly formal but at least the idea
is here. So there's no big difference,
at least the way I see it with value
function and seeing it
probabilistically. But the terms of
Epistemic value is an exploration drive
which you also find in reinforcement
learning. Maybe not in this exact
expression. I think that the exact
expression that was given in the paper
of. I. Think it's pezulo
and for sure
I. Know is on the paper.
It'S very economical
way to define Epistemic value. So it's
an exploratory drive, you can always add
to the value function. But there's a lot
of problem of trying to explore in fact
your environment to find the good
policies because if you're in a state
space that is continuous it's really
difficult to resolve the p one EP.
Yes, it's like if you knew which
curiosities you could get rewarded
from you would have already known
the answer to the search.
So that's one of the
challenges with Pragmatic value it
converges well to expectations. But then
this work really
focuses in on Epistemic value and shows
what it can do alone as a driver.
So how would you bring Pragmatic value
into this formalism? You just add it.
You can put the value functions of some
of rewards in some way and then you add
the Epistemic value. In fact, when you
look at the formulation in terms of
belief MDP for POMDP, the Curiosity
Epistemic value is simply a value
function, nothing more. It's a one step
value function. But I mean this is like
just playing with definitions but so you
can always add a drive for exploration
and this is something that's really
often done in reinforcement learning.
I think it's even standard in not this
way, not exactly special, but there's a
book that's called Reinforcement
Learning state of the art and they
introduce this exploratory drive.
This is a book maybe that has. Ten years
or something like that. So it's
something that you add up. The way we
will do it now. Is we can put some
drives with respect to preferences and
then you add for example, an epistemic
value and you try to just solve the
optimization problem. But in terms of
formalism, if you look at the belief
MDP, it's nothing more than a certain
value function. So it's not cool.
So space remains
when we translate through it or
when we whether we're in the Euclidean
or in the projective setting space is
basically what is not changed
through action. Is that the case?
Okay, yeah.
The thing is that there's a bit of
technicality so the way that we use is
we use a chart for the projected plane.
So we need to use homogeneous
coordinates, so we need to take away a
lower dimensional plane. So that's why
we always have the. Same like in the way
that we encoded, we always are in r
three because we chose a chart, we chose
homogeneous coordinates and we did
projective transformations from one
homogeneous coordinate to another
homogeneous coordinate but it always
lists to a projective transformation.
So what is hidden in the way. That we
write it is in fact. We don't have the
same space in the first case we have
ecclesian, in the second we have
projective. But the way as we use charts
and we don't put all the details of the
fact that for example, you can compose
two projective transformations even if
you write it in charts in terms of
homogeneous coordinates and it stays a
projective transformation. This is
something that is okay but we just don't
write it this way. We stay in charts and
so that's why there's a similarity
between because we. Want to implement
it, there's a similarity. Between the.
Projective case and projected case.
Have the same state space r three. But
the space of transformation is really.
Different and in fact they are not the
same space. But what is important for us
in terms of space is just to tell
yourself that if you take away
everything that is inside of space,
everything that populates space, you
take it away. What you're left with is
with this kind of concepts which already
takes into account the fact that when
you act you're not changing the space
and there's no single point that is
singled out. This is very important
because it's a very typical like it
types a lot the object you're looking at
if you move there's no point in the
space that is changing. There's no point
that is single out. And when you move
the space is not changing. So you know
that you already have inside of your
space a change of charts that is
encoded. And even more when you can
imagine that you take the perspective of
somebody else. And this is really
something that is at the basis of the
space we consider is that the space is
simply. A way to support the fact that
you can change charts, you can change
perspectives. And so it's including this
idea inside of agency that we're trying
to do. So maybe I was not clear in. The
way that I said it first, but I think
this is really important.
It's the water we're in. So it's a very
interesting way to approach it. And it
reminds me way back when, actually
almost three years ago when we discussed
the projective consciousness model and
phenomenal selfhood in live stream
number nine. And we
talked a lot about flipping between the
Euclidean and the projective modes.
How an agent could have on one hand
a space in which a
book is a rectangle and yet also be
seeing it very close to their face so
that its visual projection
was different and yet here there
was different behavior associated
with the frame alone. So what's
going on there where even though they
apparently can be reconstructed from
each other,
what flips can we flip from thinking
more Euclidean? And then in that
situation I'm a plane 30,000ft
above my city so there's nowhere I need
to go. But then in the projective
setting we do have this kind
of inbuilt epistemic drive
to be near.
I think it's hard coded.
One of the things that it can be useful
for is communication. So using space as
a way to. Communicate, taking it as a
priority that. We have very different
architectures. The way that we treat
information are not the same. We don't
have exactly the same connection,
neurons and everything. But we still
have a common framework in which we can
discuss, for example. And visual
information is something that is very
immediate for us, which is not obvious
if you take the perspective, the point
of view, if you go from the idea that
it's rebuilt and the environment you're
living on is not exactly the space that
we see. There's something that we
constructed for functional reasons
and that one of them could be that we
can communicate very directly with it.
So I think it's hard coded that. The
state space needs to have this action
and that all the agents share this
action but they don't share the same
architecture. So it gives a common base
for. Discussion like true actions, for
example, change of perspective.
So it's to answer the question eclean
projective we're not going in the
direction in terms of research where
we're trying to say that you can go from
Eclean to projective for the same agent.
So agents are hard coded with a latent
space which has some structure and then
we try to exploit it for function, for
communication, for multi agent like.
Behavior so that they can collaborate.
Okay, so each agent is within its own
projective setting and then the
Euclidean sets the stage and allows
that multi perspective. The Euclidean
space, which is the outside. World, is
just here in this toy. Model because
it's a way to reference the
configuration of the world. But for a
network, this would be, for example,
the configurations of its sensors.
So it's just here. There's this kind of
ambiguity between space and space. So
outside space, which is Euclidean and
inside, which is projective, but the
outside space is just a way to discuss
configurations of something that is
related. To the environment. So it can
be like your sensors, the configuration
of your sensors or something like this
information coming from your sensors.
So you just give a space from it. And
the geometry is really in the.
Reconstructed world that is internal.
But being able to do networks that do
this is somewhere that we're working on
now. And it's not that obvious because
there's a lot of algorithms. The problem
algorithmic problems that we try to
solve. And that we need to solve. And
this toy model is really like the
ambiguity comes only from the fact that
it's a toy model. But what is space is
inside it's, what is reconstructed.
It's the thing that we perceive space
from sensors as being a whole, as being
something that structures the
information. So, David you
want to say mean. Yes indeed in
the talk that you are referring to, I
was giving and also kenneth williford if
I remember. Well, yeah, indeed. The toy
models encoded a certain world model in
an Euclidean way. And then using
homogeneous coordinate and this kind of
stuff to do the projective
transformation, we just transform the
Euclidean space into a projective space
and you can go. Of course you can invert
it. I mean, there is an onliner
division, but you can invert it anyway.
So you can go from one to the other.
But Gregor is right. That it. Was a
choice of modeling. It was a bit
motivated by my experience as a brain
scientist. There are reasons to believe
that memory, for instance, place cells
and grid cells deaden. Though there are
new hypothesis about their hyperbolic.
Characters but usually they are thought
as encoding space in an ecclesial
manner. So since when we project future
action, we use sometimes and we have to
use memory or even if we do remembrance
of the past and we project ourselves in
the scenes in the past, there is this
access to memory systems that we used to
think, and probably this is still the
case, encode information in an Euclidean
manner. So it would make sense that then
for the conscious access, there would be
some operation that would allow us to go
from Euclidean to projective, which was
implemented that way at the same time.
But this is way beyond my abilities in
math, so Gregor will correct me, there
is a way of seeing projective geometry
as being more general, as an extension
of a fine space by adding point at
infinity. So if now you think about a
projective space with a metric.
Basically, the projective space. Is an
extension of Eclidean space. Am I saying
something completely false? No,
it's one way to seeing it. And there are
also a lot of operations that use
dialogues, I would say exchange between
projective and Eclidean. If you think
about multiview reconstruction of 3D
Eclidean space from multiple shots in
your camera you take several shots of a
building from different perspective and
then you can use a deterministic
algorithm approach using epipolar
geometry to kind of infer under some
prior that basically all lines that
converge at points at infinity are
actually parallel. Then you reconstruct.
You go from projective to ecclesiast.
So there is a deep relationship between
the two that is possible and probably
functional.
Yeah, that's about it. And Epipolar
geometry is a subset of projective
geometry. Just to give some context.
David has. A better intuition on
projective spaces than me. This is like
so when he faced notes
he really has a very intuitive,
physical, personal, visualization and
most of the time he's right.
Are we experiencing a projective
geometry or what is it like to
experience a projective geometry?
So one problem that there is with this
model is the fact that you. Need to
force the point at infinity. To be so
the plane you take away from the
projected space has to be behind. And so
you're not really working with real
maps. No, you can always extend them.
That's okay. But the thing is if you
want to see it in the way that we see it
us, which is we have something in front
of us I find it a bit restrictive to say
that you cannot see what's behind you.
I mean, you never see it, right? I mean,
you can imagine it which is not the same
thing because you change your frame. So
I can't answer really this question.
I'm just pointing out the fact that for
me it's very perturbating to think that
I have a plane that corresponds to
discontinuity with respect to I
have a plane that destroys completely
the way that I can think about movement
behind me. Which is that if I had to
imagine I had a whole space that is
around me and not just in front of me
things would be very weird in terms of
transformations. But it's not something
that is not possible. This is what
happens when you take psychedelic. You
basically allow the projective
transformation to have all its degrees
of freedom. But in the perception, like
in sensory motor processes this
is calibrated, this is restricted. So we
have to choose certain subset of the
group. Basically it's only certain
projected transformation that will be
used in practice. But now if you go into
mystical experience or you take drugs
they are going to mess. Precisely.
That's the hypothesis with those
parameters. And now you have the full
fledged 15 degrees of freedom
transformation. And you see things that
are very weird, like that looks like
mandalas or things like that. So that's
something you can get when you leave too
much freedom to the projective action.
Basically. What if
what we're seeing, quote in front of us
is behind us or something like that?
What do you mean?
What was the issue with not being able
to see behind us? The issue is.
So if you want to see the projected
space as a 3d space, as the way that we
see it now, you need to take away a
plane and basically projective
transformation. So there's a sort of
plane at infinity on which you can I
mean, it doesn't exist in the projected
space. It exists only in the way you
define an Ecligian chart, like a 3d,
like R three chart with a plane
that is taken away, this plane that is
behind you. If you apply a projective
transformation in front of you,
everything will seem fine. You're
expecting like it's things that you
experience but then once what happened
is that it can send things at infinity
back behind you. So this is something
that is a bit I mean, for me so
you can write it explicitly there's no
problem mathematically but if it's
really the way that we experience it,
it's extremely weird to think about so I
prefer not thinking about it. So this is
the only thing and I don't take drugs so
I leave it to other people. It's true
that taking drugs in this context makes
complete like you could model it in the
projective framework and not in the
Euclearian framework because you have a
huge amount of projective
transformations that make sense more
than the one that are related to actions
in the art. So in the presentation I
gave there was a way to relate ecclesian
frames to projective frames under
certain axioms and in fact you have a
huge much bigger space of projective
transformations than the one that are
restricted by the actions
of the agent. So the actions of the
agent inside. Of the real space. So the
Euclidean space induce projective
transformation in its internal world but
there are much more projective
transformation than these actions and so
you can imagine in this setting having
very confusing states of your. Mind in a
way. Which you
cannot. In the appeal case.
I wonder if a creature or a robot
with 360 degree cameras
would it not be so perplexed as it
wouldn't necessarily have a visual
before or a visual in front and behind?
And the thing is how do you glue them
together?
You still have to pick a point of
convergence, right? I mean you need to
find a way to do multimodal integration.
Like, if you want to have a camera
that's 360, you have the space to
represent it, so maybe you can represent
it as a sphere. And in this case,
the sensors are different. So it's not
necessarily the same robot than the
models that we are considering. But
there might be also another homogeneous
space. So g space, it's a space acting
which corresponds to the rotations.
If you say that, it can look 360 and
then you can rotate and the space of
observation stays the same. So you can
always imagine acting on it and so you
can imagine like having another g space
structure. And the good thing about it
is just with respect to the perspective,
if you have an agent that can take a
different perspective on its
environment, which depends on its
sensors, on its actions, on the kind of
data you have, then you can define g
space and you can do exactly the same
setting. Everything like it's made in
the more general context so you can
apply it. And so it's not limited only
to the projective case. We come
from the PCM projective consciousness
model. But the framework
now, or at least the way to replace this
framework inside of optimal
control is well adapted for any change
of perspective and not just projective.
Awesome. Well, where are you going to
go to next? Where will the epistemic
drive take you carrying
forward? So there are two projects now.
So the first one is to be able to maybe
David can talk,
to implement it so that it can be used
for monitoring behaviors or to be able
to predict behaviors or to analyze it.
So you have model of behaviors of.
Agents like maladati's behaviors,
things that we already published but in
a more limited context now to make it
inside of a computational framework so
that we can use it to analyze
experiments with humans. So this is the
first project which is ongoing with
several students. So on the page that I
put on the first slide, there's all the
work that we're doing, the people who
are working with us and we're very
grateful for them working with us and
all the ongoing work in this direction.
And there's the second one, which is
more like, let's say machine learning.
And so for me it's very important you
have effective algorithms, things that
you can really use in practice, things
that you can really implement and
implementing when you have group
structures. There are many, many
problems that appear. How to do
sarcastic optimal control when the
latent space is a homogeneous space is,
I think, a completely open question. I
start to have answers in this direction.
So I hopefully the work will
come out soon, let's say January or
something like this. But there's a huge
work in this direction.
Cool. Anything else you want to add?
Thank you very much for the invitation.
A lot to think about mentally
rotate project. I mean, after all, as
you even alluded to with communication,
this is a perspective taking question.
Technology is adding some new flavors
and methods, for example,
asynchronous communication, but it's
synchronous for the agent when they
perceive it. But all these different
modalities of communication and it's
quite interesting to think about and
just really cool that you and colleagues
are pursuing that from empirical data
analytic and from theoretical
mathematical approaches. I mean,
on this side for communication. I think
so. It's something I find extremely
interesting. More generally, if some
people want to work on the project,
please tell us, and I will be very
happy. And even if you have money,
please tell us, and we will be very
happy.
I agree. Great.
We're very open. You can always send us
a mail. We'll be very happy to discuss
about this. Cool. Okay,
well, thank you again to all.
Till next time. Okay, see you.
Bye.